welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on what it takes to
become valedictorian at your magic
school and no it doesn't involve
manipulating the very fabric of time so
you can take double the amount of
classes hermione why would you do that
hermione you big old nerd that's insane
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brother brun hello mt it is insane
that hermione was allowed to manipulate
time to take classes
cut her a break mcgonagall like what's
going on
maybe lighten her load geez louise if i
had a friend that told me that had they
had a time machine they were like i'm
just taking extra classes i'll be like
you know what
i'm stealing this tonight
yeah i hope you know that i'm taking
this from you and you're not gonna have
it
uh big old
yes i've been star portal back to the
dimension that looks like my apartment
just for this episode
i got out of the blue dungeon but i'm
i'm back in another dungeon anyways
what's our big question for today
brandon
well mt in the recently released doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness we
see our good doctor steven strange
finally pay his respects to wong as
sorcerer supreme by giving him a
ceremonial about oh very respectful very
respectful and it looks like his quest
to reclaim the title of sorcerer supreme
has for now come to an end but how does
one even become sorcerer supreme in the
first place it all leads us to today's
big question which actually was asked by
sam on our discord just goes by sam on
the discord here's the question
how do you earn the title of sorcerer
supreme in the mcu
ooh
good question and i'm glad that we chose
this question because i have a brother
named sam so
just kidding favoritism that's how it
works nepotism every time but that's a
great question because so much of doctor
strange's story in the mcu is tied to
him becoming and then losing the title
of sorcerer's supreme but so much of the
details of this succession happen
off-screen but can we look at all the
tasty clues there to try to figure out
how a master of the mystic arts earns
the rank of sorcerer supreme so let's
start off by looking at the written word
in the beginning was the word and the
word was god and the word was with god
and god in this case is stan lee
[Laughter]
but yeah let's take a better look at how
the title of social supreme gets
assigned in the comics yeah the social
supreme according to marvel fan wiki is
a practitioner of the mystic or magic
arts who has greater skills than all
others or commands a greater portion of
the ambient magical energies than any
other organism on a given world or
dimension and in the early comics
featuring doctor strange he earned the
title of sorcerer supreme when the
ancient one died similar to what we saw
in the first doctor strange film and in
marvel premiere number 10 from 1973 we
find doctor strange battling schuma
gorham the big old eyeball inside of the
mind of his very own master the ancient
one and basically shumagorath is using
the ancient one's mind as a portal to
access our dimension and doctor strange
realizes the only way to stop
shumagorath from conquering our
dimension is to kill the ancient one
which is really sad and hardcore and he
does this by shutting down the ancient
one's mind closing the portal and saving
the day then the ancient one appears to
stephen and isn't even pissed he's like
thanks for killing me dog i'm now one
with the universe great job you're the
source of supreme now i wish this
happened sooner
that's like nuts though right like
schumacher is like in the mind of the
ancient one stephen just hops in there
and it's like hmm how do i stop this
i gotta shut this mind down dog like i
don't even think he checks with the h01
he doesn't like come back out and be
like yo what this is okay
you're cool with dying my dog
this also sounds like the story he would
tell everyone else when like he comes
back his sources are pretty supreme like
what happened to the ancient one he's
like guys you you won't believe this
was in his mind and i had to go in his
mind and kill him
and then he showed up and he was like
hey thanks you're serious thank you so
much for killing me
i have to go now
i always think about the fact in how in
toy story one woody tries to freaking
kill buzz lightyear and i feel like if i
know if he actually succeeded in like
shoving him in the corner of the bed or
whatever he was trying to do he would
probably help like window and stuff yeah
i mean like it was hardcore
buzz called me and he wanted to jump out
the window oh that's so weird
but he's using his arm he's like i'm
okay guys he's like
and every time a new toy shows up the
toy illuminati gets together like we
gotta kill this joy we gotta kill it
it's like one different toy like one toy
from like each section of al's toy barn
[Laughter]
the illuminati oh my god
but how did the ancient one become
sorcerer supreme that happened when the
ancient one known as yao became the
first mortal of earth to meet with
eternity and she gave him the amulet of
agamotto and declared him
oh did he turn to your woman
uh i think it turned into a woman i'm
sure that they don't have a gender i'm
sure there isn't a big old eternity
penis
somewhere in the universe
just floating out there that'd be
terrible
they gave him the amulet of akamoto and
declared him the source of supreme of
earth and this all happened in the 14th
century which is uh just just like
yesterday honestly just like yesterday
time flies when you're
i don't know talking to your eternity
well yeah yell was like a
around for like a long time as the
ancient one much like in the movie right
and right so sometimes he was not
sorcerer supreme like he would pass off
it's kind of one of those things in
comics right like they established the
story with with the ancient one and
doctor strange and then later go in and
fill in all this other stuff and kind of
retcon things a little bit because like
before yeah there was like agamotto was
like the first sorcerer supreme right
and then like merlin was a sorcerer
supreme at some point isaac newton was
like a sorcerer's supreme at some point
like the title changed around a lot but
like yao had it like for the longest
amount of time
so they called called him the ancient
one yeah yeah he was around for a long
time
just kicking ass and taking names yeah i
want to see a yao comic or just an
ancient one comic in general like an
ancient one central
comic and i i honestly want an h1 series
on disney plus because i i think she's
one of my favorite characters mcu there
was also another way of determining the
source of supreme which was introduced
in later years of marvel comics and that
is by the trial of vishanti
that name sound familiar that's right
no longer with us really great singer
though um
every few decades the most powerful
sorcerers in the world would gather to
compete in the tri-wizard tournament
after they picked their name to the
goblet of fire did you push it
did you put your name in the dumpling
you put your name in a couple of the
fire that you need to freaking chill the
app out it's a child
yeah every few decades the most powerful
sorcerers in the world gather to compete
in some mystical competition where
magical beings known as the vashanti
will determine who should be the
protector of the realm and hold the
title of sorcerer supreme and steven won
this competition twice one time even
besting get this doctor doom
god knows magic oh a lot of magic
he's a real jerk
yeah he's so ugly doesn't he want to
show his face just kidding he's actually
quite handsome when he gets his face
fixed um
he comes in second place in that
competition and after he loses the stick
steven strange he's like okay you get to
be source of supreme and he's like also
can you come help me get my mom out of
hell that would be awesome
it's like okay i guess i have to now you
just be a mess so nicely
like it doesn't matter who your worst
enemy is if they're like can you help me
get my mom out of hell you're like okay
i'll help you with that one that's the
thing
man everyone deserves to have a mom even
doctor who has a mom okay
exactly in hell in hell
where's she belong
i'm sure dr doom's mom did something bad
too did at least one bad thing but on
his third appearance in this competition
he winds up losing to a sorcerer who
wasn't even there and isn't even from
earth loki which is yeah wild location
but what this trial of ashanti shows us
is that you don't need to wait for the
current source or supreme to die you can
just win the title in this tournament
which is yeah and wild and i kind of
want to see that yeah it is interesting
because like marvel comics initially
sets up that like you know steven
strange he's the most powerful wizard
you know angel one dies from steven
strange
and then he gets to just be like source
of supreme because the ghost of the
ancient ones like you're the sorcerer's
supreme now congratulations then i'm
sure like the comic writers were like
well we're kind of in a pickle here
because like
we we need to take away or we need to
have the risk of the title leaving
stephen without killing him right
because they don't want to kill dr
strange she's a popular character they
don't want to kill him but they're like
ah it's a good narrative device right to
have him lose his title or at least the
the threat of losing his title right
yeah right so they kind of come up with
this trial of the shanti thing which
uh as you pointed out you know read the
book of ashanti uh it's a very powerful
magic book but then there's in this
triad it's like these magical entities
they call the shanti like a plural right
a group of beings right um so yeah so
that's interesting and it could be
something that we have in the mcu right
if one day they're like let's have a
tournament to determine who's the most
powerful wizard but yeah it seems like
in the mcu it's mostly just been the
ancient one for a long time a long time
she's been holding that title hmm
didn't want to give it up too until she
did it i want to give it halfway through
doctor strange which is one of my
favorite parts of the movie where she's
just like you know what
i should probably just die
[Laughter]
uh
i've been watching the future for a
while i know i can't see past this part
i should i should i guess i'll just die
i guess i'll die look for me does that
guess where they throw the peace sign
and disappear
but yeah let now let us talk about the
mcu source of supreme because that's
what the comics have to say about
becoming sorcerer supreme we gotta talk
about the mcu now well much like in the
comics this ancient one in the mcu held
the title of sorcerer's supreme for some
time thanks to some power from the dark
dimension now
[Music]
all women go to heaven i don't you know
this this is a fact of life no we don't
know her age which would be rude to ask
you don't just ask a woman
why would you do that but mordo does
inform us that she is celtic and the
fact that she was able to live for a
long time and presumably holds the title
for most of her life means that she
could conceivably have outlived anyone
who knew about the true rules of
succession and in theory with her
additional dark dimension power she is
the strongest sorcerer on earth yeah
you're right let's think about that for
a second like she
she's using dark dimension power
right and in a way it's not like she
she's besting dormammu but she's
taking his power
keeping him out at the same time because
she's
she's keeping the spells to keep him to
release him hidden right or to draw him
into uh into the realm she's keeping all
other sorcerers from finding the spells
to access this power so in theory yeah
she's like the strongest uh uh defender
she's got the most juice basically she's
got she's got some really powerful dark
dimension juice yeah we have no idea how
old she is conceivably lived out
everyone else who would who would have
been there when she got the title right
right unless you're an asgardian or some
other
or when woo maybe maybe
or you're an eternal right you have no
idea how she got to where she is you
have to take her word for it no one in
theory no one's written it down there
might be a book in commentary somewhere
but she's had enough time to change
whatever history she wants right she
writes the rules here if someone
challenges that she's just like that's
not how it works but we're taking her
word for that that's true and it makes
me think you know so if she's celtic
she's in she's not obviously in norway
but she's in the the norse region do you
think the asgardians were aware of her
uh they they seem to be very magic
minded people they would they wouldn't
know of her don't you think i would i
would hope so because like we do know in
the comics that um are the stone age
avengers i believe right um it's when um
the the the social supreme at the time
which is agamotto does team up with odin
and like he doesn't have a relationship
with odin so
hopefully that there is some type of
rapport between you know kamar taj and
odin considering that odin in the mcu
has taken trips to earth and like you
know helped try to help out the people
of uh norway so i think that you know
any any extra dimensional threat any
threat that comes to earth yeah ancient
one commentary is on it so like if odin
comes by they're gonna be like
who are you why are you here so
yeah for sure i think they definitely
have in theory
comes to earth right she's she's a witch
so she would be aware of like magic
wielders and would probably sense
that like she would probably know that
every
realm has a sorcerer supreme right
because it's not just an earth thing
every planet's got a sorcerer supreme
right every round every dimension like
you said like you know clia from the
dark dimension she's the sorcerer's
spring the dark dimension so it's like
frigga must know that there are
sorcerer's supremes and probably checked
in on earth to be like hey
i'm freaking i'm the wife of odin maybe
you heard of me i don't know
you're the source of supreme just wanted
to bring you these asgardian fruits and
a little asgardian uh ipa
try it out you know just want to say hi
from one magic wilder to another let's
be cool so let's be cool i just want you
to know that i am the head witch in
charge so uh you're talking to hwic okay
so i am the first lady so i i'm the best
so they must have talked they must have
talked okay that's a good point and then
you also brought up wen wu i wonder i
mean do you think wen wu and the ancient
one ever came to blows ever came across
each other i want to see that fight so
bad because it would be one of the
coolest fights in the mcu um but like i
think that
that they have to have come to blows
when was like doing [ __ ] in in uh
i don't know when commentary got built
or created or when the ancient one made
her way to comtaj but that's in a
similar region to you know uh in asia
where when wu was taking over a
country's
millennium ago or whatever so uh they
could have crossed back that would be a
bad ass battle to see come on whatever
let's see that seriously what if season
two bring
the like all the actors from from
because i want to see some cool ass
fights again kashank she's one of the
coolest
action movies that we've got in the mcu
and i guess we should also consider the
internals too right do you think the
eternals knew of the ancient ones or the
ancients
no there is no way no in my opinion that
there is no way that the eternals in the
ancient one have not come into contact
because i feel like the power of the
eternals like the actual cosmic energy
that they wield is the same source of
the the sorcerer's magic energy these
like
magic you think it's the same yeah i
think that this magic magic
yeah i think it's the sun i think that
everyone gets their power from the sun
and that um sorcerers use their like the
sun magic within them that they've
absorbed their entire life
to you know have these orange strings
and like to do all this orange magic and
the the eternals are the same way and so
like i think that because of this their
similarities in like their power source
and we we know that from chongqi that um
you know his rings um affected the the
magicians of commerce
in a similar way maybe like they can
sort of feel each other because they're
they're running on the same power source
there um so yeah i think that there's
because of that relation they have to
and like because like they're just
fighting deviants and like deviants
threaten our reality they must have like
come across each other at some point
right yeah yeah and then i wonder i love
the idea that like you know ajax and
fina cross paths with the ancient one
and then like a thousand years later
they see each other again and they're
like hey you're still alive and they're
like okay yeah you're still left it was
like
okay
okay don't ask me questions
that would honestly be
so like
if they just ran into each other at like
a coffee shop they had a really great
conversation didn't talk for like a
couple of hundred years and they ran
into each other again and they're like
you're human right and they're like hey
i'm you and i'm human right
[Laughter]
also i mean you point out about wong and
the ten rings right he looks at the ten
rings at the end of shanxi he's
examining him he's totally shocked so if
the ancient one did come across wen wu
maybe she like forgot to remind him
about that you know she's got a lot of
history up there she's gotta tell people
right and like i wonder if she was like
dying she's like bye steven and she like
dies and she's like oh [ __ ] i should
have told her about one woo
all right
dumb idiot
you had a thousand years to tell
somebody come on that would
be so funny it flaked she was passing
away and she was like she's like all
right goodbye stephen
there's this guy and he's got rings but
the amount of his fingers on his arms uh
she gets cut off because she dies yeah
yeah what i'm about to tell you
will change the course of history
[Music]
okay okay now i'm ready
there's a celestial beard in the earth
do something all right here we go
oh yo if the ancient one oh my i never
considered that because if each one knew
about it
i mean you have to imagine that the
masters of the mystic arts know about
celestials but maybe it's one of those
things like the government won't tell us
what it what's in area 51 because it's
going to blow our breaths and we're
going to
a society will collapse and no one will
believe in anything anymore maybe it's
the same thing with ancient one she's
like i know about celestials but i
cannot tell people about this the
masters of the mystic arts will get so
obsessed with trying to stop celestials
and it's like a futile effort because
you just can't stop them but yeah it's
better off not knowing about them and
just to live your life oh my gosh you
know bro cause like you know like the
whole thing with um the ancient one in
doctor strange one is like you know like
death is a natural part of life and like
it has to happen and like that's what
irishmen tells um cersei so it's just
like maybe she would be 100 on board
without happening the destruction of the
earth that is
seen stephen across universes be like
the lives of one does not matter in the
trillions of calculations of the
multiverse i butchered that line right
paraphrasing but like yeah i don't know
too many too many sorcerers are like
these little things don't matter on the
small scale on the grand scale of like
the universe so it's like she probably
did know and she was like i'm gonna make
sure to die before this this month is up
in here
[Laughter]
like
this film also introduced the heads of
the hong kong and london sanctums in
sorcerers that we didn't see in the
first film and were presumably killed by
casilius and they acknowledge wong's
authority when they come to protect
camertaj by bowing out of respect as one
does as it is ancient custom what are
you doing steven and the whole bowing
thing is initially played for last
between stephen and wong of course but
there is a lot of significance to that
it shows that as a powerful sorcerer you
are showing your allegiance to the title
of sorcerer supreme and are not here to
challenge that authority and if you
doubt of the authority of the social
supreme in theory you could challenge
that title whether by a vote of no
confidence or through combat which would
be again really cool to see a really
cool idea
yeah i think it's a great point empty
because like
the bowing thing it was played for like
kind of jokes like hahahaha right but it
was very significant at the end and i
think you're right that you know if you
have all these powerfully magical people
in theory if they're if enough of them
are against what the sorcerer supreme is
saying they could challenge that they
probably have like some sort of
democratic system set up you know
multiple times in like the first doctor
strange and in the multiverse of madness
we see kind of like regal looking
sorcerers who are like teachers they
kind of make their joke in the first
doctor strange right where he goes uh he
walks up to him here and he's like oh
you must be the ancient one and like
they're like
no it's this lady who knew about the
celestials it didn't warn us
so it makes sense that you have these
these elder sorcerers who are also very
powerful and they probably could if
enough of them got together and they
were like we don't trust you as sorcerer
supreme anymore they probably could
overturn it and go through some whole
process or yeah just like whip out their
magic and be like i'm the boss now
that's basically what kaiselius tried to
do right he tried to do
kind of take over by force so i think
this bowing thing which was probably set
up by the ancient one because she's been
around for the longest time it's
probably her custom
but it's important because it's
basically showing like i'm not here to
threaten you i trust you or i will do as
you say you know i lend myself to you
because that was another thing i thought
was a very interesting line in the film
it's hong kong and in london show up and
it's not like they're just like yes sir
right away sir they're like we're here
to offer our support so they have like
some level of autonomy it seems like
they could be like because as a supreme
you probably got to worry about the big
picture you don't have time to
micromanage every sanctum so i do kind
of like that they put that in the film
it's very similar to how you know the
custom we have of like shaking hands i
believe it dates back to like medieval
times which basically is showing that
your hand is empty you don't have a
sword in your hand because most people
right sword use your right hand for your
sword by showing the empty hand you're
saying i don't come here to attack i
come here out of peace i'm not holding
my weapon so i think this bowing is like
very important it's showing that like
yes we still trust you we're on your
side you can be our sorcerer supreme
yeah man and like it's so easy for for
egos especially when you're dealing with
like stuff like with power because like
that's all these people like these
sorcerers are it's all you guys are all
power wielders and so like egos can
easily be like oh why should he be
source of supreme when it should be me
like what the heck
exactly like i'm stronger than wrong so
like yeah it is really important for the
entirety of the world to be on the same
page because as we learned from doctor
strange one each of these sanctums are
key to keeping the dark baddies out of
our dimension if all three are gone then
like we're done so if there is no
synergy then they're all going to fall
so like there has to be
some type of like respect for one
president of magic which is wong
um
well it's also yeah it's probably a
thankless title too because if a door
mom who shows up or us you know or
something else that's an
inter-dimensional being shows up to
destroy your your world you have to go
fight it it's your job now buddy you're
a source of supreme you better step up
sucks
you can't really call out for work
like yeah you you gotta have to do this
man i'm sorry yeah uh oh man i would
never i would never even take the job i
don't want the job
i'd rather be uh intern supreme a lot
less stress
um which is who we saw in no way home in
terms of
i'm sorcerer middle management oh i have
some i have some people under me but i
mostly take orders from the executive
team
[Laughter]
i'm sorcerer of the toilets
i'm so supreme of the toilets now let's
talk about wong as social supreme
because steven was made source of
supreme after the ancient one died even
though he was a brand new sorcerer
because of his incredible ability to
just absorb information because he's a
big old nerd and he defeated dormammu
within the dark dimension and was able
to demonstrate the ability to utilize an
infinity stone specifically the time
stone um which as we learned from doctor
strange was just hard to do as a
sorcerer like a lot of people couldn't
even open the damn freaking eye of
agamotto because like i don't know the
spells just i'm too dumb but stephen was
like i've got time christine doesn't
love me why not um let's read some books
instead of getting laid um but yeah when
he was blipped wong was the next
powerful were in line so the title
passed down to him which makes a lot of
sense because wong himself was really
into reading as when we first meet him
he was a librarian so he probably knows
a lot about the mystic arts but now that
stephen is back the title doesn't pass
immediately back to him so by the rules
that we laid out today shouldn't the
title sorcerer supreme go back to
stephen yeah i mean i guess if we're
saying that the sorcerer supreme is the
most powerful sorcerer in the realm and
you've already established that doctor
strange was that at one point in theory
you would think the title would just
like shoot right back over to him
because he still would be the strongest
one but do we think this blip
made him weaker in any way than juan do
you think wong really is more powerful
than steven i think that
there is probably
a huge um advantage to have being alive
those five years because like as we
learn from spider-man far from home when
taylor's fury is talking to peter he's
like there's a lot that i need to catch
up on i've been gone for a while so like
you know
you need the intel to be able to do your
job right so like if stephen has not
been around those five years and wong
was it's just it doesn't make sense for
a newbie to be like all right i'm going
to be in charge of magic i've been gone
for five years you just give it to wong
because he's like i've been here i know
what's good i know what's the big
threats on like the current horizon and
like you know and stephen that's his
friend that's one of his best friends
he's like i'm not gonna take it from you
anyway so it just makes sense for you to
have it because it's more efficient and
it's just right in general i wonder too
if if when when stephen initially got
the title if in some way wong was like
yeah let him have this because juan just
watched london and
hong kong sanctums get destroyed
uh yeah and saw the ancient one die it
was probably like man this is a lot i
don't want to be switched for supreme
like this is a guy could do it if he's
so good right wong died wong straight up
die
then he comes back and he's like keep
keep messing with him
you know what go for it i can't i forgot
that he did die yeah wong owed doctor
strange big so he's like you know what
i'm not going to fight it he can have
the time stone he obviously he knows how
to use it so let's go for it
and stephen did beat uh dormammu but
then he loses to thanos wong didn't lose
the thanos stephen lost to thanos uh and
then wong wong went home like a smart
person yeah i went off like a smart
person he's like i'm not supreme not my
problem
not paid enough for this
but then when when he fights thanos
later yes stephen wins but wong also
wins that fight too so wang is
undefeated against daniels but uh
steven's one and one so so wong does
have like better cred now i think than
stephen and even if steven is
a little more fancier with his magic and
those are a couple more spells i think
wong is definitely in a better position
to beat sorcerer supreme and maybe
they've learned that like yeah we don't
need our sorcerer's supreme to be the
most powerful protector of the realm it
can be the second most powerful and we
can use the other guy as a tool for when
we need to do some stuff some dark stuff
well i think now too that he's touched
dark magic so much and he's got the eye
i don't think he could ever be sorcerer
supreme now i think he's tainted
that's true that's so true because he
does have darkness in him and like like
even though like because we know that
the scarlet witch is the most powerful
magic user on the planet oh they were
like hey why don't you that's a great
point too why aren't you
supreme yeah that's actually a great
point mt
it's cause like she's a dark magic user
so like she should 100 be sourced but
she 100 thousand percent should be the
sorcerer's free but because she's a dark
magic user uh she can't be because
because of that darkness and now that
strange has that in him i don't think
that's such a good point like that's
probably what will keep him from
becoming sources supreme in general
about the end of darkness iii
well and his argument would be like hey
our longest reigning sorcerer supreme
was using dark magic the whole time
so you should let me be the source of
supreme but that was under the table
they didn't know and they've maybe
they've updated the code of ethics maybe
all the sources had to sign they had to
sign a new employee handbook that was
like i will not use dark magic for real
this time
man like it's and like i i i think it's
even more crazy because i think that
this is my personal theory that the
ancient one was using dark hold magic
specifically because i think dormammu is
the doctor strange variant that pizza
papa strange jumped into and destroyed
this universe which made the dark
dimension hence like the first incursion
so i think that uh you think dormammu is
a doctor strange 100 because he's voiced
by a friend of the cover batch
it's a good point and like at the end of
at the end of the movie we see clea come
from the dark dimension he's like hey uh
we gotta fix an incursion uh which is
this dark didn't she say here
i think that's what she meant she's like
you as a multiversal problem
you and i'm putting a heavy asterisk on
this u caused this incursion
it's like i can't get mad at her mama
because it wasn't his fault because he's
a victim but uh i'm gonna make be mad at
you yeah um
so empty do you think do you think wong
is rightly the sorcerer's supreme now i
yeah 100 and like in considering
what we saw wong in chung chi when he's
like kicking ass he freaking kicked
abomination's ass
we don't know like a wong is probably
just going around the world just just
kicking all sorts of ass yeah and like
you know maybe even like you know as a
show of strength for these tournaments
that he has to fight us so
it's a supreme it's like yeah i'm taking
that abomination i'll take you down too
so don't mess with me
and i think i don't think these london
and hong kong sanctums would
they wouldn't like steven as their boss
i don't think at all
i think they would really be offended by
it and yeah i think wong is like a good
person to be in that position
to unify all the all the the
masters of the mystic arts yeah man
because like you like the the main theme
of this movie this new movie is like
steven always has to have the knife and
like he needs to relinquish the knife to
someone else which is why he just bows
to wong he's like all right i'm
relinquishing the knife of protecting
the the humanity to you yeah in like if
we said in doc strange one that the
people that he worked with was like all
right he's kind of an [ __ ] i don't
really
really like working with him he just
likes being in charge so like yeah i
think that he they wouldn't really like
working with him at all like zero
percent so you're totally right there
this is for rachel you big fat white
nasty smelling fat [ __ ] why you took me
off the
schedule good points a lot of good
points for me today brandon you're so
smart you're smart too and deal with it
i think we were smarter
i wish they would i wish they would lay
all this out for us so we didn't have to
do all his work for uh marvel studios
but i think i think we've come to a
pretty good conclusion here hey i think
hey i love talking about marvel just on
youtube because hey
i hope they never do the work so that we
get to talk about this stuff forever
and hey be sure to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com because our partners
at epic hero shop have released a ton of
new merch related to doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness including some
fun new shirt designs and some adorable
gargantos stickers gargantos did not
deserve to die like that please find
some stickers in memory and you can
still grab our latest obsession shirt
shattered madness before it's erased
from the universe forever forever
because it's not gonna come back do not
ask for it back when it's gone so to see
all of our awesome merch options and
support the work that we do here at new
rockstars please head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that help bring big question to
you
take it away brandon
you got it spring has sprung and summer
is just around the corner with the
constantly changing weather it could be
hard to figure out what to wear for the
day luckily faraday makes it way easier
they make the perfect clothes for all
seasons faraday is a family-run brand
making high quality timeless clothing
with modern design and functionality
their clothes have that kind of
effortless style we all want to see in
our closets they have pieces that mix
and match with ease and it will feel
like you have your own personal stylist
when you shop with verity
i love their legend sweater shirts i got
a couple of myself i can roll up the
sleeves when it's a warm day but roll
them back down when the sun sets and the
temperature starts to drop in this cool
california desert weather uh and all all
day long i look great and i really like
this shirt it's super comfortable i
agree you agree empty agrees uh and
faraday's so confident in the quality of
their stuff that they have a lifetime
guarantee of quality your whole life
even the ancient one's life if you live
for hundreds of years
use your magic to keep faraday in
business and they'll fix your clothes
for free uh yeah don't replace or fix
your clothes forever no matter what talk
about making it easier to get dressed
that's what verity does and right now
faraday is giving all big question
listeners 20 off can you believe it 20
off uh so head to faritybrand.com
big question and use code big question
at checkout to snag 20 off all your new
spring staples that's code big question
at faraday f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand dot com slash big question for 20
off again
veritybrand.com big question now it is
time for our bite size questions next
time
jelly's inside delicious now
brandon
can wanda warp reality to be able to
lift thor's hammer and this is from
spoon fiesta on discord thank you spoon
oh yes thank you spoon well wanda's
ability to warp reality as the scarlet
witch is incredibly powerful but is it
even more powerful than asgardian magic
and the odin force right because that's
all what's tied up into mjolnir
considering that in the mcu wanda's
abilities were innate magical powers
possibly part of a prophecy of catholic
we don't know that yet that's how it is
in the comics but maybe that's true in
the mcu we don't know but then yeah he
also like in the comics didn't come like
literally give baby wanda powers right
or like right you physically did that
but we don't know if that's true here uh
but so she had these kind of innate
magical abilities you know we saw that
in one division when she stopped uh the
bomb from going off but then those
powers got enhanced uh via the mind
stone which is of course one of the
infinity stones so very powerful cosmic
magic that's tied into her chaos metric
uh so i really think it wouldn't be a
problem for wanda to warp the reality of
the worthiness enchantment you know
potentially even removing the
enchantment entirely if she wanted to
but she could probably also just turn
mjolnir into like a caesar salad or like
a pile of buttons or something like she
doesn't
need to pick up milner ever or like
touch it but i definitely think she's
strong enough to change the magic around
it remember mjolnir didn't always have
that enchantment right i think a young
in the comics like a young odin used to
use mjolnir but it was just like a
powerful hammer that the dwarfs made
like he didn't have a worthiness charm
then he just put it on there because his
son was an [ __ ] and he had to teach
him a lesson
[Laughter]
it's like
it's like putting a a lock on your gun
in the house it's like yeah well
i think that's a that's a fair thing to
do i think everyone should put a lock on
their gun
yeah that's what i'm saying like that's
odin putting the lock on it's like don't
lift this like a thor until you're old
enough yeah to be happy able to use it
so you're responsible enough to wield
this gun yeah i'm not letting you touch
it um
but let's not also forget
that while hella never wielded mueller
she didn't pick it up she did stop it
and like hold it it didn't like blow
right through her or like you know slam
her down to the ground she was like
holding it for a second and then she
destroyed it we know of course that
hella possesses as guardian magic and
she probably has like a little bit of
the odin force inside of her because she
did
fight with odin she was like the
firstborn this is all within mcu of
course she was like the first
child so she has a lot of magic but she
certainly wasn't worthy when she gripped
mjolnir and was able to destroy it and i
would think that wanda is probably way
more powerful than hela
so i think wanda could definitely even
maybe even without warping reality might
be strong enough with just chaos magic
to like
pick up mjolnir oh yeah for sure i think
the the actual enchantment has to like
be like physical contact lifting up so
like we they do talk about it in uh age
of ultron briefly it's like hey uh
elevator's not worthy but if you put the
hammer in an elevator would still go up
elevator's not worthy yeah yeah they
talk about like that if yeah all the
weird things you could do like if it's
on an airplane can you get it up in the
sky
and so like i think that chaos magic is
sort of like the elevator in this
scenario where it's like hey
i'm not lifting it up myself with my
right hand it's true
um and like technically the the
enchantment is getting the powers of
thor so you can lift up the hammer fine
but like you're not going to get the
power of four if you're left with the
hammer like like the elevator wouldn't
get the power of four so yeah so maybe
she could pick it up but she wouldn't
get the power of thor like her magic's
not strong enough to put to change that
i like that i like that because like
juan is too strong to not be able to
lift up too strong yeah she can do
whatever she wants with that hammer it's
more that she doesn't care right she
doesn't care at all she'll take your
mouth and blow your mind
um what now but
what mouth exactly
oh yeah here's another bite-sized
question if doctor strange astral
punched a moon knight who would come out
this is from crispy chrissy always with
the good questions crispy chrissy thank
you uh yes well i think i'll tell you
right off the bat i think mark spector
would come out
but let's think about it for a second
okay our best evidence comes from
uh avengers end game when we saw the
ancient one punch the smart hulk uh and
bruce banner came out uh right and we we
actually talked about this on big
question before as a white side question
uh bruce and hulk are like the same
soul right
right in the comic books they kind of
explained in like 1978 in like the
incredible hulk that the hulk is not
like a mutation of banner's brain or a
separate entity inside of banner but
rather it's like a manifestation of his
childhood range and anger because in the
comics his father's very abusive uh and
so
bruce has like a multiple personality
disorder and the hulk's personality came
from that disorder it was kind of like
amplified by the game of radiation right
so if we think that moon knight has like
a similar thing right if mark and
stephen and jake likely if they're part
of like a did kind of persona and
they're multiple personalities
if we go by like the rules of smart hulk
and bruce i think like the base
soul would come out whatever the og soul
was and if we believe that to be mark
specter i think it'll be mark spector
and i also have a theory that maybe jake
lockley is the og
person and that mark and stephen are
really manifestations of jake lockley
and he's allowed mark to think he's the
main the alpha persona because he uses
mark i think you were talking about this
how like he uses mark
uh mark's identity when mark's not
knowing it and like
goes around like getting apartments and
stuff under mark's name and mark's not
sure
like i think he's using these markets
steven as personalities to get around
the world because jake lockley is so
dark
uh and and destructive that he had to
manifest like nicer personalities like
mark is a nicer personality than steve
er than jay glocke so i think whatever
the the alpha persona is i think that's
what would come out if the astral punch
happened now do you think it's possible
they could be separate we could see like
three souls come out i know i think that
only one would come out and i think
you're exactly right i think it would be
mark spector because of those reasons
like you you just brought up because
like in the comics i think it's actually
established in canon that the hulk does
have d.i.d and yeah yeah like you just
said like the the the the hulk
personality sorry the hulk alter is just
like you know his intentions and your
personality yeah right and so like
that's i love that you brought it up
because like when the ancient one did
push him we did see only bruce come out
the only thing that would make me think
there could maybe be multiple
if if the astral punch happened that you
could get multiple souls coming out
would be when we were in the dua we're
on the ship
uh with towerette and she has two hearts
for stephen and mark uh and they have to
weigh together now she doesn't weigh
jake's heart it is not involved at all
but it still found balance with just the
two hearts it makes me wonder if because
there are two hearts are there two souls
also is this going to be an instance
where there's multiple souls they're of
the same person but they are like really
completely different souls that's the
only thing that makes me think you could
get two
or more spirits coming out of moon
knight when you do the astral punch
this is true because he did we did see
multiple hearts there so was that that
all could have just been a metaphor
tower it was trying to establish that's
deep to be like i'll show i gotta make
this i gotta make this let's make these
hearts i guess because if each if each
person in the afterlife sees a different
con construct i i don't know if i don't
know how the heart thing works but like
you could potentially i think
you know moon knight's the one
potential for having multiple souls in
one body that would be crazy but it's
possible but i think it would be
whatever the alpha one is is what would
come out and it's probably mark i
definitely agree with the mark answer um
but yeah thank you brandon you're
amazing as a person as always but now
it's time for our box of scraps oh bunch
of squirrels
i got his hands
with a box
tony is smarter than me i'm to kill him
with the tower
[Laughter]
i'm going to eat this i'll smoke the
cigar tony and freaking kill ya is there
a nickname or title that you wish the
world would address you as oh yes
of that um supreme chancellor brandon i
always i did legitimately i always
wanted to be a junior i thought that was
such a cool nickname
to be like a junior and a junior you
know like indiana jones he was a junior
i thought he hated it he wanted to go
buy indiana they named the dog indiana
he was henry jones jr but he wanted to
go by indiana uh but i always wanted to
be a junior but i could see how that
could also be annoying because you're
like i have to have like my father's
name i don't get my own identity
someone's calling the house they don't
know who they're looking for as
everyone's got the same name it'd be
confusing uh i always wanted i did
always want to have a nickname junior i
thought it was really cool okay um
i do like junior junior's nice junior's
a nice little name yeah yeah um but i'm
not sure
maybe one of these don't don't give up
on your dreams
it's so funny that you could like once
you're just born and you're not a junior
you'll never be able to be a tutor yeah
i didn't get a saying i didn't get a say
in it
oh man well hopefully in another
multiverse you are a jew there's a
junior junior variant
i think for me
god um
god um
thinking small huh
start small i've worked my way up um i
don't know i think i i would like to
just be known as
i don't know just a good man that's all
oh good man well it's like a game of
thrones they get all those cool
nicknames like the king's leia the
mountain
the hound like we've really let that go
by the wayside i just want to be known
as like a good man like i just feel like
it's like men suck these days just like
yo that's a good like that's a good
title to have i don't know
the good man
good my superhero name good man mr good
man off to save the day
i
that's basically captain america that's
that's essentially the entirety of
captain america he's good man but yeah
that's that's what i would probably
choose which is not a cool answer but
hey that's a good answer that's a cool
answer that's a cool answer thanks bud
thanks dude but that is it for this
episode of big question as always as
always thank you so much to brandon for
joining me this episode his insights are
always so valuable please follow him at
grin and barrack on twitter because he's
amazing follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] and insane theories
and follow new rockstars here on youtube
and all of our social media platforms
make sure you hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video and of course hit us
up on discord to continue the new
rockstars conversation because we're
always talking about weird [ __ ] over
there and it's just really fun so head
on over uh hit the link in the
description box to join that
conversation because it's really fun and
yeah as always thank you guys so much
for spending time with us we appreciate
every single one of you also new
rockstarsmerch.com buy a shirt it really
helps us a lot and uh we love you guys
we'll see you guys next time goodbye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]